Scott is with us in Indiana hey Scott
welcome to the Dave Ramsey show how can
we help hi Dave thanks for having me on
sure I've been debating with my wife
she's been telling me to quit my job for
a few months because my side hustle is
is getting to that point to where it's
it's becoming equal to the day job last
year I cut back on hours of my day job
two instead of five days a week working
four days a week just because the side
hustle was needing a little bit more
time now we're to the point where I
could comfortably quit and we have a
pretty pretty good stockpile of money
put back
what's the sod house okay it's well
you're gonna kind of laugh at this
because I've heard someone else call in
but I raised exotic snakes okay remember
laughing about it I just created yeah
I'm scared I'm not laughing it's
terrified so the question is this if you
put more time into the sawdust one will
it make even more money quite a bit more
okay so why wouldn't you it's nice to
have that that comfort level of having a
steady paycheck every week and I was
kind of worried that the whole koba's
nineteen thing was gonna almost crash
the market but over the last three
months sales has kind of been through
the roof and yeah and it's allowed us to
put back so much money and we're just
kind of stockpiling to get our debts
paid off the only debt we have it's our
mortgage and we're on track to pay it
off within the next four years
yeah Scott yeah listen you and your wife
are debating this what's the key
sticking point for you we know what she
says but is it just that I want a little
bit more money in the bank before I do
it because you clearly it's obvious you
know you need to eventually step
full-time into this side hustle it's
your dream so what's the what's the
number I thought so so what's the number
that makes you feel comfortable
I was wanting to have 100k putbacks what
do you have now about 70 so how long
would it take you to get to the hundred
K it's hard to say we're kind of in the
middle of the breeding season right now
and eggs are starting to hatch Oh
roughly Oh month or ten months or years
um six months okay let me stop you're
saying did what what did your parents do
for a living
my dad was a salesman for Kevin Cecil
for a long very long time he was one of
the top salespeople in the country
yeah my mother said he didn't have a
steady paycheck no he was he was good at
this job yeah his skill his skill
brought his security which by the way is
the only place you get security I was
making a pile of money and my granny her
my grandpa worked in a steady job for
alcohol aluminum his whole career and my
granny's bless her sweetheart would
always asked me when I was gonna get a
real job and I was making a pile of
money running a business but to her it
wasn't a steady job but let me tell you
there is you're only as secure as your
ability to create an income not at
you're never secure based on someone
else giving you a check
that's that's mythology and so you need
to quit tomorrow your wife is right
that's my opinion can you jump in yeah I
don't disagree I just wanted to walk you
through Scott what you're really facing
your for you have got some fear and
you've got to own it you've just got to
say I'm afraid that if I don't have a
hundred that I'm not secure and I just
wanted you to be able to walk through
and see you're not silly but is your
fear a little silly and I think in this
case it is you got the snake thing yeah
we we have two kids two children how
long you been doing that snake thing um
it's been a hobby of mine for 30 come on
you made money on it how long has I made
money on it yeah 25 years this is not a
joke of a steady paycheck dude yeah yeah
I know I just wanted to get her calm
yeah and all I'm trying to do is help
you see you're not silly but your fear
is whispering to you and it's telling
you a lie that this is unstable and this
is risky to do this and there's no risk
Dave and I are objective we see no risk
I think your wife is telling you the
truth
be okay man you got 70 grand in the bank
you're fine you're gonna win bigger when
you go full-time that's what I needed to
hear yeah go dude
be free I'm talking about it for the
last year and then tell me anything
happened yeah if you tell me you've been
doing this for six months I'd be a
little more worried okay if you told me
you had no money in the bank I'd be a
little more worried if you told me you
weren't making really good money at this
but it was your dream I'd be a lot more
worried but in any of this I mean you've
had a full time at the stinking job here
with your business for a long time I
only got their nails admit it you're
their man congratulations touchdown you
did it yeah very well done sir very well
done